einkaufen ohne mundschutz mehrere
bundesländer überlegen die masken
pflicht im einzelhandel wieder
abzuschaffen lösung für
flüchtlingsschiff die migranten auf der
ocean viking dürfen in sizilien auf ein
quarantäne chefwechsel und jubel über
das doodle meister fc bayern feiert mit
dem pokalsieg den zweiten titel in
dieser saison
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem sonntag
an meiner seite ist norbert könig für
den sport hallo und 100 zum schutz vor
corona gilt derzeit bundesweit beim
einkaufen masken pflicht mecklenburg
vorpommern überlegt jetzt sie ab august
abzuschaffen und möchte noch andere
nördliche bundesländer mit ins boot
holen weil es dort so wenig corona
infektionen gibt ein völlig falsches
signal sagen nicht nur
gesundheitsexperten anselm stern
berichtet rhein geht es nur mit maske
das sind die regeln die frage wie lange
noch
mund nasenschutz im laden ja oder nein
darüber gibt es jetzt eine doch ziemlich
kontroverse debatte das ist irgendwie
nervig man geht nicht so gerne einkaufen
und der letzten zeit also man ist froh
wieder raus ist aus einem geschäft sind
dann die maske wieder ablegen kann
ich fühle mich so ein bisschen sicherer
aber mit muss ich ihnen ganz ehrlich
sagen also und ich finde das auch gut
wenn dann andere eingetragen das
stimmungsbild in mecklenburg vorpommern
wo der wirtschaftsminister heute
vorprescht er will die einkaufs masken
pflicht abschaffen wenn das
infektionsgeschehen so gering bleibt
sehe ich keinen grund länger an der
masken pflicht im handel festzuhalten
der handel reagiert positiv denn dem
ausgedehnten shoppen dem anprobieren den
verweilen stehen die masken oft in weg
für den einzelnen in deutschland wäre es
natürlich gut wenn die maske pflicht
aufgehoben werden könnte so weit dass
unter pandemie gesichtspunkten überhaupt
möglich verträglich und auch sicher ist
gehen wir sehen dass die größte
kaufzurückhaltung in der tat auch in der
masken pflicht liegt die masken pflicht
sei eine der wichtigsten maßnahmen im
kampf gegen das virus daran zu rütteln
eine falsche signal warnen kritiker
werden wir die masken pflicht zum
beispiel in geschäften aufheben würden
dann würde das die kunden aber auch
insbesondere personal gefährden und wir
würden auch die ware kontaminieren es
gibt keine gründe dafür dass zu tun der
streit über die anti virus maske beim
einkaufen er hat gerade erst begonnen
die korona pandemie habe nichts von
ihrer dynamik
eingebüßt betont die
weltgesundheitsorganisation sie
registriert weltweit so viele neue
infektionen wie noch nie gestern waren
es an einem tag mehr als 200 12.000 in
deutschland dagegen bleibt die zahl
unverändert im schnitt der vergangenen
sieben tage haben sich täglich 390
menschen neu mit dem virus angesteckt
corona hatte die personalfragen in der
union zurück gedrängt jetzt wird wieder
über den kanzlerkandidaten diskutiert
der bayerische ministerpräsident müller
sagte dem tagesspiegel er könne sich nur
einen kandidaten vorstellen der sich in
der krise bewährt hat sein kollege aus
nordrhein-westfalen laschet 70 gut
gerüstet seine regierungserfahrung sei
sicher von vorteil sagte er der passauer
neuen presse
die von der bundesregierung angekündigte
studie zu rassismus bei der polizei wird
nun doch nicht durchgeführt
innenminister seehofer halte ein solches
forschungsprojekt für nicht sinnvoll
entsprechende vorkommnisse seien
absolute ausnahmefälle so ein sprecher
die studie war von der europäischen
kommission empfohlen worden
der unabhängigkeitstag in den usa das
ist traditionell ein tag an dem
gemeinsam gefeiert und die einheit des
landes beschworen wird
nicht so wenn der mann im weißen haus
donald trump heißt der nutzte diesen
feiertag vier monate vor der wahl für
verbale angriffe auf politische gegner
und demonstranten
ines trams berichtet fliegerstaffel über
washington doch es waren längst nicht so
viele gekommen wie präsident trump sich
das gewünscht hatte die die kamen
pflichteten ihm bei
die andauernden proteste nach weißer
polizeigewalt müssten ein ende haben
die demonstranten nichts als ein mob wir
waren entsetzt über das was in
minneapolis passiert ist aber man baut
doch keine brücken in dem man dinge
einreist ich begrüße proteste geraten
sie aber außer kontrolle wie in den
letzten wochen zerstören wie statuen und
städte dann ist das nicht akzeptabel
spaltend und unversöhnlich die botschaft
von trump im garten des weißen hauses
seine vorgänger hätten nazis bekämpft
sagt er sich lobt er für seinen kampf
gegen demonstrierende amerikaner heute
bezwingen wir die radikale linke die
marxisten die anarchisten die
unruhestifter die plünderer und leute
die oftmals gar nicht wissen was sie tun
[Musik]
tranxx gäste dicht gedrängt meist ohne
maske die korona infektionszahlen im
land explodieren doch er sagt alles
unter kontrolle
unsere strategie funktioniert gut das
virus verschwindet in einer gegend und
kommt mit seiner hässlichen fratze
woanders zurück doch wir haben gelernt
wie wir die flammen löschen
aufgeheizt die stimmung im land gerangel
zwischen jump anhängern und jungen
schwarzen der vierte juli dieses jahr
kein tag der einheit darüber kann auch
das feuerwerk nicht hinwegtäuschen
im mittelmeer geht das flüchtlingsdrama
weiter wenn auch weniger öffentlich
wegen corona seit tagen kreuz das
rettungsschiff ocean waking vor der
küste siziliens an bord sind 180 aus
seenot gerettet migranten die situation
auf dem schiff drohte zu eskalieren
jetzt gibt es eine lösung annette
hilsenbeck zehn tage lang schon herren
die migranten auf der ocean biking aus
wegen der korona krise blieben
italienische und maltesische häfen
geschlossen
heute nun schickt italien ein team von
medizinern an bord des rettungsschirms
dass die geretteten auf das corona virus
testet die hilfsorganisation berichtet
das medizinische team wurde von den
italienischen behörden geschickt und hat
an allen der 180 geräten an bord proben
genommen
sie sind gerade eben von bord gegangen
am nachmittag dann verkünden
italienische behörden die migranten
sollen morgen auf das quarantäne schiff
novi sa wechseln auf dem fährschiff in
porto empedocle befinden sich schon die
von der deutschen ziele geretteten
menschen in quarantäne
die lage auf der ocean viking war bis
zuletzt angespannt mehrere migranten an
bord hätten versucht sich umzubringen
sagen die helfer die menschen waren vor
ihrer rettung in holzbooten in seenot
geraten auf der fahrt über das
mittelmeer
wir sehen jetzt mehr menschen die über
das zentrale mittelmeer kommen vor allem
aus tunesien das ist unsinn
es waren ungewöhnlich hohe zahlen in den
letzten wochen die geretteten auf der
ocean viking werden morgen wieder in
sicherheit seien
doch bei gutem wetter erwarten die
helfer schon bald die nächsten migranten
auf dem meer mitten in der korona krise
haben die kroaten ein neues parlament
gewählt soeben haben die wahllokale
geschlossen
der konservative regierungschef andreev
language liegt laut prognosen deutlich
vorn er dürfte aber auf
koalitionspartner angewiesen sein
genauso wie die oppositionellen
sozialdemokraten um da war bernadette es
wird mit einer schwierigen
regierungsbildung gerechnet und jetzt
der sport norbert die formel 1 ist aus
der korona zwangspause zurück mit 16
wochen verspätet und das erste rennen in
spielberg österreich für sebastian
vettel beginnt die letzte saison für
ferrari direkt ernüchternd nur platz
zehn nach einem fahrfehler in einem
nicht alltäglichen rennen dass
mercedes-pilot valtteri bottas gilt die
geste gegen rassismus vor dem
saisonstart in dem lewis hamilton eine
schlüsselrolle spielt er werde das
überholmanöver von alex erben auf seinen
zweiten platz zu aggressiv ab und erhält
eine 2 sekunden strafe ferrari-pilot
schale claire lange zeit nur in der nähe
des podiums greift sich platz 3 von
sergio perez und drückt durch hamiltons
zeitstrafe sogar auf rang zwei vor
die überraschung des tages lando norris
auch vorbei an perez er bleibt trotz
berührung im rennen und profitiert
ebenfalls von hamiltons fünf sekunden
last
das team feiert das erste podium seiner
karriere der 20 jahre alte brite ist der
mann des tages
für sebastian vettel ein tag zum
vergessen er wird nur zehnter das
frauenfußballteam vom vfl wolfsburg hat
zum sechsten mal nacheinander den
dfb-pokal gewonnen durch einen sieg im
elfmeterschießen in köln gegen die sg
essen
die wolfsburgerinnen bleiben damit
ungeschlagen in dieser saison und das
gilt in diesem jahr bei den männern auch
für den fc bayern münchen der
rekordmeister jetzt double-gewinner
durch das 4 2 im pokalfinale gegen
leverkusen
sie haben gefeiert so gut es eben ging
nach der dreißigste meisterschaft jetzt
den zwanzigster pokalsieg wir haben das
double gewonnen und ich muss sagen die
art und weise wie wir gewonnen fand ich
großartig beim 4 2 erfolg der bayern
gegen leverkusen mag lewandowskis
treffer zum 3 0 das kräfteverhältnis im
berliner olympiastadion am besten
wiedergeben bessere bayern profitierten
am ende auch ein bisschen vom pech der
leverkusener die auch ihr drittes pokal
endspiel verloren
es ist das 13 jubel der bayerischen
vereinsgeschichte ob sie 2013 auch ein
triple wird hängt vom ausgang der
champions league finalrunde im august ab
endspielen am 23
gutes sagt wettermäßig beginnt die neue
woche durchwachsen im norden schauer und
gewitter auch südlich der donau
regengüsse dazwischen freundlicher bei
16 bis 23 grad
so viel von uns foto 14 begrüßte klaus
kleber im heute-journal morgen ist hier
petra gerster dran